[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
somebody made this but let me make a
point real quick before you even do that
oh it's like the aha yeah
video
just a nice loop of us
bobby and andrew scoot into the hallway
they're in love
they're in love
[Music]
i'm holding on to him we might fall over
because there's an earthquake happening
i could die because i'm clinging on to
a coward
a [ __ ] cow or a [ __ ] he don't know
nothing
[Music]
you like that you're such a little dick
what you said to ken
you did it you did you add it on yeah
yeah
i'd like you to sing you just you bobby
lee to sing me happy birthday quietly
smoothly sexually in your own bobby lee
way go ahead
may i say something before i go yeah
okay
you know i could do it comedically
okay okay i could do it with a smile
but i can also do it
real and in a way how it really makes me
feel about you
okay
no
now you're going for a comment no no but
now that i just said that uh-huh it
makes me laugh i know right
so just give me a second go ahead and
re-just recoup i'm sorry
why does that happen we can wait all
right no here we go
okay
you can't smile i'm not smiling if you
are smiling but just when you would do
that you're so femme when you do that
with your hair i know but don't don't do
that that's like so sorry don't smile
this is a real moment man okay i won't
i'm not gonna smile
you're right i love you please i love
you i love
[Music]
to you
happy birthday
to you
[Music]
happy birthday
dear andrew
happy birthday
to you
thank you bob
hi um what's your name
hey i'm andrew hi andrew where are you
from 37. tell me about yourself man how
long you've been singing yeah i'd love
to be i'm glad i'm here
yeah i know how long you've been seeing
it i'm nervous and in front of you
lionel richard this is my first time in
science oh all right all right buddy
just we're last calm down we've all been
in this place you haven't you're been so
good since you were born
yeah that's funny pal so um what are you
gonna be singing for us today today
we'll be singing and not unfortunate
today i'm gonna be singing it's not an
original song sir but it is my favorite
song and it inspired me to become a
singer myself okay well let's hear it
okay okay
i get knocked down but i get up again
and you're never going to keep me down i
get knocked down but i get up again and
you're never going to keep me down
thank you
but i but i thank you i still can i just
do this no he drinks a whiskey drink he
drinks a vodka drink security drinks a
lot of drinks security drinks he sings
his songs never mind about the good
times he sings the songs that remind him
of the best times
[Music]
[Laughter]
can we do it again i'm being real yeah
and try to really sing a song as if
you're really gonna try to what's wrong
with tubs no no no no
no no i want you to sing a whitney
houston song or something that i really
want you to try your best to get through
a whitney song this is the heart
honestly imagine you're [ __ ] imagine
this right okay imagine they said you
know
if you you have to try your best or okay
or or all your whole family's gonna get
sick
are you serious yeah
okay here we go all right so i'm gonna
do the introduction again
at the interview first okay i just did
the theme
jesus
hey um welcome what's your name hey
andrew
uh how long you been singing pal
since i can
six years okay
what are you gonna be singing for us
today one of my favorite song songs of
all time one of my favorite movies okay
go ahead please thank god
don't i'm not your parents are getting
sick okay
[Music]
tell me something boy
aren't you tired
i mess it up
tell me what
tell me something boy
aren't you tired of trying to fill that
void
do you
need more
ain't hot keeping is so hot cool
hey man i'm not gonna [ __ ] laugh when
you do it yeah you're next now yeah
you're no and i'm done now now it's your
turn go ahead all right sorry go ahead
all right so next contestant come on i
was really going for it yeah yeah yeah
yeah that one what's your name
hi i'm jules hi jewels
this will be good i'm from cebu
where's that where is cebu where's that
philippines the philippines wow are you
a refugee yes oh my god why did you come
over here they love heartfelt stories
yeah why did you come to the united
states because i want to be a singer oh
wow that's great how were you able to
come over here financially are your
parents financially stable
no i just walked through here
you walked the walk you walked from the
philippines all the way here yeah
wow well i get it i get it threw the
bearing straight you walked all the way
up to the bearing straight yeah yeah
yeah did you see any eskimos
yeah you did all right so what what what
are you going to be singing for us today
i will be singing my heart will go on
wow what a song it's a big song all
right
[Music]
every night in my dreams
i see you
i feel you
that is how i know you
go on
far across the distance
and
spaces
between us
[Music]
this is the big part this is the big the
only part that matters how you're gonna
get in all right
you wanna take it to hollywood or not
getting kicked
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i
ready
that
the heart does
go on wait what is that song called
my heart will go on i want to see if i
can titanic i want to see if i can reach
that that chorus to to near far yeah
[Applause]
here we go
near
far
wherever you are
i believe
that the heart does
go on
this is this is a throwback i posted
again because
um timing wise it's pretty great
who is this lady though you know what
maybe i too could be ninja
i
want to be ninja
i
want to be ninja
i want to chop chop chop chow down
down to chinatown i
want to be ninja
i started training hard i think i could
go far
i am a natural that's matter factual
i learn to chop real hard i fight with
credit card i use
[Music]
this video came out a long time ago but
i saw it again in my i was deleting
stuff oh yeah i want to let you let's
just hear the chorus again oh no please
don't tur it's gonna put me to work
[Music]
i learn by ninja kicks while watching
netflix i try to everything
like on the big screen and you guys you
know what i might do it i might be a
ninja soon i
gonna be ninja
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
this asian lady how is she standing
there through this there's four minutes
of this all right first of all if i was
that agent
turn it off okay it's off all right
if i was that asian lady
take chow down to chinatown
it makes me so it makes me feel like the
rudest [ __ ] i've ever heard in my life
yeah yeah i was going through my folders
at my old on my phone because she
doesn't realize how difficult it's so
rude how difficult it is to be a ninja
yeah the levels are insane she could
never be ninja yeah because there's
different levels number one you have to
be able to climb a tree she can't climb
a tree there's no way there's no chance
right number one two you have to have
this enough
breath stamina to [ __ ] do the blow
gun
yeah it's you gotta have that she
doesn't have any she doesn't have that
she has to be able to throw a star hard
enough to puncture skin yeah yeah right
she can't do that she's got to be sneaky
as [ __ ]
she's not sneaky at all imagine her
being a ninja what's that white lady in
the tree
if there's a white lady what do you mean
look
that's a ninja i'm ninja yeah yeah ma'am
please get down yeah she look at her
skin too i practice every day
it just don't freeze when ninjas wear
sunscreen
ninjas
i really wish i could oh my god from
sippy cup you know i won't give up
i gotta try my best you can't expect no
less that chow has not a clue
it's too good to be true hide making
you know what this reminds me who this
is by the way who is that this is a girl
that sells murphy beds in orange county
that's the she did this as a promo to
sell murphy beds you know murphy beds
are no the beds that go in the wall the
cabinet well the cabinet beds you know
they pop out of the cabinets
have you ever seen that i don't know oh
i know what it is yeah yeah yeah
old-timey murphy beds yeah that's what
she's selling she's like she opened a
murphy bed company this is like years
ago yeah but this is she put this out
for promo let's see the course one more
time
it's one of my favorite courses
this is getting fun
you guys i think i almost a
[Music]
take chow down to chinatown
this is the most racist [ __ ] i've ever
heard of my life and it makes me laugh
so hard
this poor asian lady you know what's as
hard a ninja yeah being a navy seal
right yeah it's the hardest thing in the
world imagine a chinese dude yeah or a
woman yeah i
want to be
navy seal
uh you know i mean at a party i don't
think it's that offensive
a navy seal yeah well if it if it was a
chinese
ninja is a cultural thing right right so
i think it's what the accent is what's
offensive about really about it too it's
very offensive yeah it's really good
yesterday was father's day and uh oh boy
i miss my dad and the thing is
i wanted to um write a father's day um
song and um i told you i was gonna do
that too yeah you promised me and i
thought you weren't gonna do it i'm
being serious and and i forgot about it
and then we were sitting here outside
waiting for you because you were late um
i wasn't late i was getting you
sugar-free red bull rudy
was i getting sugar-free red bull yeah
see
okay but was were we here were we here
before i called them dude you called me
it doesn't matter no no you called me
all right can we do the father's day
what are you angry about you always do
this to me you trample on me trample
trample your turn you trample trample
you trample trample that's you travel
trample yeah yeah go ahead trampoline so
um you know while we were waiting for
you um because we were early cause i got
sugar will you go yeah and i um i wrote
a song real quick because i write a lot
of music on my i'm garage band so i just
came up with i have an old older like
weird song i mean so i wanted to i wrote
a song for my dad okay let's hear it all
right
daddy i love you
daddy why you died
happy father's day daddy
daddy i can fly
daddy i miss you
why
[Music]
i'm sorry i took photos of you while you
were dead
and sent it to the heart says what was
in my head
you were dead and i whipped out my
phone
i can't [ __ ] believe i did that [ __ ]
i'm all alone i miss you daddy i love
you
okay there we go that's a song
very good
very good song i miss your dad and uh he
died
um 11 months ago you know and uh wait
was it already 11 months ago
oh my god
it's terrible and uh rest in peace daddy
[Music]
you